[Music]
okay everybody so this is my review of
dexter new blood episode two this time
instead of it being written by
showrunner clyde phillips it is written
by warren leonard and again is directed
by marcos siega so if the first episode
you can look at it as is the episode to
catch us up with where dexter is now in
this story about 10 years later and
understand where his head is at this
episode really is what feels like the
start of the season meaning it is the
start of the main story arc and where
we're possibly going to go at this
season so it almost feels like its own
premiere on its own right in that case
and you see where they're kind of
setting up different interesting things
that can happen and what's really
catching my attention mostly right now
is the mystery of
who harrison really is what he's really
like and they do a good job with toying
with you throughout the episode
about is harrison like dexter is he
different and what i like is that
they're kind of giving you a little bit
of both where we don't really know what
happened in this big reveal that hannah
unfortunately yvonne stravowski who i
love as an actress is dead in the show
so i guess we're not gonna see her again
but anyway we we learned in that time
that he was going from foster home to
foster home so something was happening
during that we learned that he used to
be someone who had a problem with drugs
now he's clean he knows how to pick a
lock really well in the beginning of the
episode he kind of stares at knives like
dexter does but then you get other
things like you know he does seem
more
friendly he's not as awkward as dexter
uh when dexter assumes he might be and
then wants him to stay in his cabin for
the days like no i'm gonna i'm gonna go
talk i can handle myself you know he's
got tendencies that are different so
it's kind of pulling with you teases
both ways so it keeps that mystery alive
and that's going to be interesting
throughout the season as we learn more
about this mysterious harrison and how
much he actually is like his father
dexter i also love in that case too when
we see that dexter realizes he's not as
awkward as him and he goes and talks to
audrey that again what's been the
shining point of the show to me is
having deborah be the new harry here for
dexter it's so fascinating because
it seems like jennifer carpenter and
michael c hall are having so much fun
doing this it's fresh and it's just a
nice
voice to have challenging dexter in what
he's doing and having those two sides of
his mind combating against each other
and i thought this was one of the best
moments when dexter screams in the car
to himself and let's set a motion out
and we see that deborah's like you know
you are the same dexter and you're gonna
screw him up and boo hoo he's not the
serial killer you thought he was in
harrison but dexter's like i'm not the
same dexter so he's fighting these
thoughts and then she's laughing at him
in the woods where he's so sloppy right
now with his serial killing which i
thought was a great touch and it wraps
around really well with the jennifer
carpenter appearances because when he
gets his little victory at the end here
that he hate all this stuff going on
with matt you know she's like okay you
win you smug f word so it's like they
they did a good job and with that they
blended humor so well through this
episode and it reminded me of dexter at
its best when it has really good humor
with dexter's narration and there's a
couple lines that stood out to me with
that there's ones like harrison where
he's like i didn't do this you know
covering up for you i just didn't want
to cop my business he's like like father
like son i really like that but i love
when he reacts to angela and he says we
need to talk words you never want to
hear from your girlfriend or doctor and
he says in his head i thought that was
great and even humor without dexter
where angela even says to scott later on
this kid in this like goofy teen group
here that his shirt's two sizes too
small and he's just like [ __ ] like that
was great i thought that was so so funny
and besides the interest here built with
this mystery of harrison we now have
this mystery of who is our season's
killer here that isn't dexter and i love
when they have a killer on the other
side of dexter it can really bring the
season to the next level like season
four was with john lithgow where you
have a really fascinating killer on the
other side that it goes against dexter
and gets in his way and you're learning
more as the season goes on they're
slowly building that up here because
you're left wondering okay so we see
this girl from the last episode was the
same girl angela saw in the bar that was
in town angela was looking out for her
and if you forget she literally said to
her you should stay with that woman she
runs a shelter you know be careful
because we're learning i mean we can
assume that angela lost possibly a
daughter maybe a sister this person
that's brought up named iris and that's
why she's so protective maybe why she
joined the force about missing woman and
specifically missing indigenous woman
and this theme is brought up throughout
the episode but it's also foreshadowed
last episode with this girl who's going
to have this unfortunate fate here where
she's in this motel and this is where
this killer is watching her we see he
watches her through a camera we didn't
actually see her dead body yet but i'm
sure that's going to open the next
episode but you left wondering what is
his mo we don't know yet we don't know
how he kills his prey we just know kind
of how he traps them now so it's gonna
be interesting my theory is it's i hope
it's not this because it would be too
obvious at this point but we already
know that clancy brown was cast in the
show he's a great actor he is playing
kirk caldwell that's got to be his
eyeball we're seeing watching on the
screen right like he's got a certain
look to him i feel like that's
definitely him it makes the most sense
and he usually always plays a villain in
anything he's in uh maybe not though
maybe he's just a villainous in his own
way as the father of matt and he gets in
dexter's way and he's not the killer so
maybe it's a red herring but right now i
think that's definitely the highest odds
but i'd love to know your theories on
who this killer might be maybe just give
me a theory like if you don't why it's
not him i'd love to hear that kind of
argument but we'll see that's gonna be
really interesting but i love the
attention to detail on this episode
stuff you gotta like just clap at
especially if you watch on a second
watch you appreciate it more like when
they set up base camp here for the
search team in the beginning of the
episode at dexter's you know angela has
this line literally says everybody come
on meet by the fire pit right when they
get there to talk about looking for matt
caldo's body but now we know in the
episode it's literally under them when
they're having this meeting of how
they're gonna do the search party it's
under the fire pit i thought that was
such a nice touch to have that line just
great stuff and it's interesting you
know as we go on through the season
you're gonna wonder if they're gonna
bring back really two
main characters are still live from
their original show in masuka and
batista were very popular characters i
have a feeling they will come back but
maybe as a cliffhanger for the next
season i don't know if they'll be in
this season i don't know how they'd get
there but i do feel like this character
of teddy who's the cop here's kind of
the goofy one is playing the masuka
escarole of the comic relief some
similarities there so we'll see if that
continues so that makes me think we
might not see masuka this year but
who knows but what i like is they're
doing a good job at really adding weight
to harrison being this grounding
character for dexter which is so
important in dexter you know the show
lost some of it's soul when rita died
because rita was that for dexter and
always grounded him and was like a moral
compass and was turning him to the man
this better man he could be you know and
i think they're kind of doing that
hopefully with harrison here because
he's got lines dexter in his head like
he's my son i lost him once i won't lose
him again and you see nice moments with
him in harrison in particular towards
the end of the episode actually when
harrison reads this letter he found that
dexter wrote to hannah but found it when
hannah died and it says reach out to me
if harrison shows any dark tendencies
you know which is totally traumatic for
a son to read that his father writes
about him and he tells him that and he's
like what was so wrong with me that he
left and changed identity and dexter's
like it wasn't you i was scared of it
was me so he is opening up a little bit
to him and not giving him the full story
but he's tiptoeing with him and he's
like i regret not being with you
especially now that you're alone i never
imagined that would happen and you see
harrison says when i thought you were
dead i looked at a photo of him every
night so you see that bond they're
really having as father and son which is
important here and will make this story
really great and i love the line where
dexter says maybe i can be there for you
now if you're willing to risk the chance
i would screw you up so it's a little
slip of dexter coming out there kind of
hinting to his son like are you sure
you're ready for this and makes you
wonder how much is he gonna let on to
harrison and vice versa how much is
harrison going to let on to dexter about
each other so i like that
fascinating relationship with there's a
mystery they have of each other here we
know dexter's story but we don't know
harrison so it's interesting to see what
we'll learn here as dexter learns and
you see there's a great line here with
harrison's like all my memories of you
were good so why are you being so shady
you know and the worst you ever did was
leave me so he decides to stay give
dexter a chance and i like they come
full circle little things like talking
about the blueberry pancakes that
harrison loved in the beginning dexter
offered him he didn't want him but now
he's like i'll take regular pancakes so
i i think that's a good touch and always
good writing getting your payoffs for
even little things i also want theories
too about when harrison is with
this group of just goofy teens here
doing bad things and being jerks you
know having to look through his bag when
he's literally just going to grab wood
real quick what did you guys think of
those sketches in the sketchbook of
harrison's i only saw there was like
this bald man uh shout out bald people
um and we don't know what that bald man
is but then the next picture in the
sketchbook it seems like it's a picture
of himself harrison on like a
stand in a courtroom and a woman walking
by him and it looks like you know some
kind of like almost like capital looking
building in the distance i wonder if you
guys have any theories there's got to be
importance those sketches that
harrison's drawing kind of may be
teasing us what we might learn about his
past and you feel bad for harrison here
it's making his character sympathetic
where he sees the kids you know looking
through his bag i think there was stuff
here where it was a little eye rolly
with him and audrey especially in the
woods where they're like talking over
each other and you know oops and they're
flirting you know it's okay it's it
could be a little more updated that felt
a little dated how that scene was kind
of structured but you know we'll see i
don't want too much again of the doofy
teens around here messing things up you
can get away with audrey and harrison
but you know we don't want to be too
much in the zone around a bunch of
teenagers doing stupid stuff it always
tunes people out and kind of can hamper
a show so what i'm liking about this
show though compared to other seasons of
dexter is what would frustrate me even
in the good season of dexter is there
was always like a b plot that was just
not even a b plot c plot that was just
torturous like a lot of that stuff would
happen with laguardia and her love
interests and stuff like that so i'm
happy this show isn't doing that right
now where sometimes with dexter i feel
like it's like half the show i'd be so
into basically anything with dexter and
everything else i'd be like oh my god
like can we get through this you know so
if they just stick to dexter's story and
then this killer and the mystery of
harris i think we're setting up a good
season here but look it's exciting how
this episode ends because you see that
dexter feels like he's won here he's
covered it up they're connecting it that
matt shot this white buck so that's why
he's on the run and he's probably just
somewhere so they're gonna you know
cancel the search in that area and you
know like i said that's where deb's like
oh you smug f word like you win whatever
but that's when we see now clancy brown
the actor who plays kirk caldwell here
matt's dad shows up and that party's
over for dexter he's reopening the
search we see he's a man of the town
here and you know he calls on the people
of iron lake to reopen the search for
his son and we see they're developing
him as he's hell-bent on finding his son
so we know already from there at the end
that he's gonna do anything possible to
find him so he's gonna be this obstacle
for dexter whether he's the other killer
or not you know he's gonna be the person
that is on dexter's tale constantly so
that should be interesting i like that
they ended again while he said that we
get the reveal of man the fire pit so
it's a cool cliffhanger and reveal at
the end of the episode so i gave episode
one nine point one this one was a little
weaker to me but still really good very
close 8.9 you know it's valuing the
relationships in the show and you know
what makes story great is great
relationships and shows even over just
character building even over plot you
know and if they can keep the writing so
well between dexter and harrison
this show is going to be great i really
feel this season will be really good and
that's keeps up here so it leaves me
excited and again some sharp humor here
with dexter's narration and i'm loving
deborah right now in the hairy role i
think it's the best decision the show
made not to bring back harry i kind of
made more of a case for that episode one
you can go back and check that out but
i'm not gonna rant about the same thing
again but again yeah i think the sky's
the limit here for this season i'm
excited what they're doing but you know
it's a little bit of setup so you might
get a little bit like you might want a
little more pace pickup which i'm sure
is gonna happen next episode especially
when they find this dead body in this
motel so that's going to ramp everyone's
reactions up to that so we'll see what
happens it's going to shake the boat but
8.9 for this let me know what you
thought of down below i'd love to hear
your thoughts i read every comment i try
to respond as many as i can please make
sure to subscribe so you don't miss one
of my reviews of dexter i'm doing every
episode this season my review comes
right after the episode airs so you're
not going to want to miss one and if you
like what i do here i'd really
appreciate if you could just sign up for
the membership down below there's a join
button it will help me do this full time
a day so i can make more reviews cover
more shows and you get special perks as
well for doing it and please follow me
at steve barley show on twitter
instagram and tick tock for clips from
my interviews with celebrities and
reviews and more of me in general and
i'll see you next time